brazil's covet 19 crisis is also getting
worse by the day the country has
confirmed its first official case of the
more infectious
variant uncovered in south africa
thousands of people are dying every day
from the virus over 340
thousand people are now known to have
lost their lives there
more bad news for brazil surging covet
19 cases
helped put the health care system on the
verge of collapse
patients are dying in and out of
hospitals while they wait for treatment
ventilators are scarce frustration is
growing
if they had properly prepared for the
scenario from the beginning
then the same thing wouldn't be
happening again
they should have prevented it from the
beginning and it would have been better
but now it's not
i have already lost relatives to the
coronavirus
i think the politician should be more
united
for months president bolsonaro has
opposed strict measures
to curb the virus and slam state leaders
who imposed tight restrictions even his
own covet 19
infection did not change his approach to
the pandemic
p1 a new variant has emerged and spread
quickly in brazil
making it the epicenter of the pandemic
again
whether p1 has the potential to lower
the effectiveness of some vaccines
is unclear meanwhile brazil has also
just recorded its first confirmed case
of the highly contagious variant first
discovered in south africa
forecast by some epidemiological
institutes
show that brazil will most likely
surpass
the half a million mark for cobit 19
deaths
rapidly approaching the total number of
deaths of the united states
the country that had the highest
absolute number of deaths
absolutely
brazil has been slow to vaccinate on
wednesday the pan-american health
organization
said the country needs access to more
covet-19 vaccines
and called on countries around the world
to help
[Music]
let's look at some other developments in
the covid19 pandemic worldwide
a court in brazil has suspended the
extension of drug
patents the move could lower the cost of
drugs to treat covet-19
it follows failed global attempts to
waive vaccine
patents argentina has announced a
three-week
nighttime curfew after infections
reached a new record high
it starts on friday in the capital and
other badly affected areas
and new zealand has now suspended all
travel from india
this comes after india reported a record
number of new cases in one day
it's struggling under a new wave
well experts are blaming large
gatherings for
india's outbreak nearly 127 000 cases
were reported there on thursday that's
the highest number
ever prime minister narendra modi urged
eligible citizens to get vaccinated
while
he received his second covet-19 dose
today
india is trying to scale up its vaccine
rollout which has only reached a small
fraction of the population
modi's government has refused to impose
a second national lockdown to curb
spreading infections but he's
set to meet virtually with regional
leaders who will decide on restrictions
here's dw's manira chaudhary in delhi
with more
india is now well into the second wave
of the pandemic we are seeing a huge
spike in the number of cases
every day in the past couple of days
india has also surpassed a daily tally
of
one hundred and thousand cases in a
single day spike
now this has created an alarming
situation most of the states are issuing
fresh guidelines and restrictions
including delhi the national capital
where we stand right now
delhi has now imposed a night curfew
that means there will be restriction of
movement from 10 in the night
to 5 in the morning and only movement of
essential services
and those people who are going to get
themselves vaccinated will be allowed
that too with an e-pass now what are
people thinking are they concerned about
this fresh spike
what do they think about the night
curfew and are they worried that the
country can go back
to a state of a nationwide lockdown
let's find out
yes we are little scared looking at the
rate of infection already the mark of
100 000 single day cases has been
crossed
i am concerned of how much it can spike
further
night curfew is a pretty good idea
because
generally uh people work in the days and
then they come back so unnecessary going
out and
catching up with people can be
restricted
if they want to impose a curfew they
should do it during day time
when more people are out there compared
to night and the chances of infection
are also more there is definitely a
sense of urgency
experts are saying that the spread of
the second wave is much faster than the
first one and that has people concerned
there's also a growing demand for making
vaccination available for all age groups
people are anxious and while many of
them believe that restrictions like a
night curfew are important
they are not entirely sure how effective
such measures can now be
in curbing the spread of the second wave